I'm not sure that there actually is a
partisan divide if you talk to people
who and I don't mean to sound at all
condescending but you know working with
members of the Supreme Court across the
entire ideological spectrum I know that
there is enormous respect for the ACLU
not only from Justice Ginsburg who
worked for the ACLU before she became a
federal court judge but also you may be
surprised from justices Thomas and
Scalia who never worked for the ACLU
before joining the federal bench but who
really respect what we're trying to do
even if they disagree on particular
issues I have a letter that I cherish
from Justice Scalia who is a friend of
mine but this was when we had first met
and he said something about I really
respect your principled adherence to and
he always has to have a little dig so it
was I really respect your principled
adherence to your open paren sometimes
incorrect closed paren maybe it even
said often incorrect positions but I you
know I know that you sometimes do that
at great cost in terms of publicity or
economics in terms of support but you're
doing it because that's what you believe
they the principles call for and if you
look at articles that have been done
about Supreme Court justices and which
briefs they read and give credence to
the weight there's just an overwhelming
support for the conclusion that after
the US government the ACLU has the
greatest credibility including in the
chambers of the justices who can be
expected to come out differently because
they believe that we are making the
strongest possible argument that would
have to be refuted in many cases but not
all you know all of them agree with us
on some issues likewise if you if you
talk to members of Congress some of the
you know most conservative Republicans
really you know they all work with us on
some issues that
all want our support where we agree and
given that we are strictly I haven't had
a chance to say this yet strictly non
partisan and nobody would would dispute
that we never and never have and never
will endorse or oppose a candidate an
official a party a group rather we take
positions on an issue by issue basis
issuing praise or criticism as the case
might be and there's literally nobody
who with whom we don't strongly agree on
some issues and strongly disagree on
others and fortunately we have enough
influence that those that they all want
us to work with them on the issues where
we agree so I think if you if you talk
to the real and there's also i have to
say this there's also real difference
between how people operate in direct
interactions with let's say our
lobbyists or our lawyers or other
leaders versus what they say in their
fundraising material I mean I had this
discussion quite a few times with Jay
Sekulow who's the chief counsel of the
American Center for Law and Justice the
litigating arm of the Christian
Coalition and you know we collaborate on
so many issues free exercise of religion
freedom of speech for anti-abortion
protesters even some of the post 9-11
privacy issues where many conservative
groups have been allies of the ACLU and
yet you read his fundraising letters
and/or you listen to his radio show and
he's you know demonizing the ACLU so I
think that to some extent i do I am NOT
a Pollyanna but I do happen to see the
glass half full you can't be an activist
without that that attitude but I think
it has to be the inflated criticism that
you hear in some public arenas such as
your let's say televised debates or
fundraising letters some political
speeches where people are playing to
their own audience trying to get a rise
out of them that I think you have to see
the ACLU bashing as a compliment that
people see us as being very effective
that we sometimes you
that effectiveness on issues that they
disagree with and so attacking aclu can
become a synonym for attacking gay
rights reproductive freedom religious
freedom you name the hot abortion
women's rights